hola de nuevo lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es resolver un problema de
integración por partes este ejercicio de
más o menos largo pero nos vamos a ir
deteniendo en los detalles para entender
súper bien cómo funciona esta técnica lo
primero que voy a hacer es escribir la
fórmula de integración por partes pero
si se te olvida no te preocupes recuerda
que puedes deducir la de la regla del
producto lo que dice la regla es lo
siguiente nos habla acerca de integrales
de integrales de cosas del estilo
efe x x g prima de x es decir si vemos
una una función multiplicada por la
derivada de otra adentro de una integral
entonces es una buena pista de que
podemos utilizar integración por partes
no te preocupes es más o menos artesanal
esto de darse cuenta de cuándo utilizar
la regla bueno eso de ahí es igual a efe
x x gtx y tenemos que restarle algo
verdad hay que restar hay que restar la
integral de la derivada de la primera
función es decir f prima de x
multiplicada por
gx es un poquito fácil de memorizar
porque hay una cierta simetría en la
fórmula verdad de x entonces vamos a ver
si podemos utilizar esto en algún lugar
una vez que ya sabes que tienes que
utilizar integración por partes vas a
ver que no es tan difícil utilizar el
método lo que sí es difícil es reconocer
cuando se puede utilizar desde mi punto
de vista y siempre uno de los últimos
recursos que utilizó una vez que tienes
mucha práctica puedes ver que los x los
seno de x y los coseno de x son buenas
pistas para utilizar integración por
partes sobre todo si no puedes utilizar
sustitución o si no puedes utilizar una
simple integración de polinomios ahora
bueno eso lo que yo hago en un examen en
la vida pues también puedes utilizar
otras cosas como por ejemplo resolverlo
por internet o alguna otra idea pero
bueno si es un examen y no te sale de
otra forma seguramente es integración
por pactos regresamos al problema vamos
a poner la integral de x cuadrada
a la x de x
entonces si viera esto así de la nada y
si yo no supiera que esto es una
presentación de integración por partes
intentaría ver si es un polinomio pero
no lo es verdad y lo segundo que
intentaría es ver si la derivada de
alguna función que esté dentro de una
composición está por ahí en algún lugar
pero vamos a ver si sí o si no a ver por
ejemplo aquí a la equis pues tiene una
equis la derivada de x es 1 pero no hay
un 1 muy obvio entonces vamos a utilizar
integración por partes y la forma en la
que pienso para integrar por partes es
que quiero simplificar entonces cuando
venga para acá cuando venga para acá lo
que voy a tener que hacer es tomar una f
x
qué va a ser alguna de estas dos
funciones de modo que f prima de aquí
sea más sencilla en cierto sentido y
quiero tomar la prima de x entre alguna
de estas dos funciones ya sea x cuadrada
o ea la x de modo que que pues de modo
de que simple se simplifiquen las cosas
cuando lo integramos o al menos que no
se vuelvan más difíciles
entonces bueno si tomamos la derivada x
cuadradas o se hace un poco más fácil
porque baja el grado y cuando tomamos la
anti derivada de ea la x este de las
cosas que no dejan de sorprenderme la
anti derivada de la x también s a la x
entonces probablemente sea una buena
idea proponer fx igual a déjame déjame
cambiar de colores es probablemente
buena idea poner fx igual a x cuadrada
porque cuando derivamos va a volver más
simple y también es probablemente una
buena idea tomar que prima de x iguala a
la x porque cuando la anti derivemos
pues no se va a volver más complicada va
a ser igual de complicada
ahora si asumimos a ver si si asumimos
que todo va muy bien entonces que nos
dice la fórmula lo que hay que hacer es
multiplicar las dos funciones reales
bueno a lo que me refiero con funciones
reales es que no estén derivadas verdad
es decir hay que multiplicar hay que
multiplicar fx vamos a ponerlo con el
color correcto
fx quest x cuadrada y hay que
multiplicarlo por gd x ahora no hay que
confundir nos diga que g prima de x
estoy diciendo que g prima de x es igual
a ea la x
ahora sigue primero a la equis entonces
gx también s a la x
estoy aquí es un gx no cree no quiero
que piense que estoy haciendo trampa
aquí voy a poner un gx lounge prima de
aquí pero en este caso resultan ser el
mismo un ala x
y de ahí queremos restar queremos restar
la siguiente integral queremos restar la
integral de la derivada de x cuadrada es
decir de 12 x
de 2x y luego hay que multiplicarlo por
la anti derivada de g prima de x es
decir pues otra vez verdad que prima de
x es a la equis y la anti derivada es
simplemente a la x entonces voy a poner
aquí en color azul para marcarla efe
cosas que tengan que ver con la f y voy
a regresar al naranja ea la x
en esto de 'la x complica un poquito las
cosas verdad porque tanto la derivada
como la integral pues es lo mismo pero
bueno con un poquito de concentración
vamos muy bien entonces déjame poner
aquí de x en amarillo vamos a hacer una
pequeña pausa para ver qué pasó
parece ser que si se simplificó un poco
porque esta integral ya se ve un poco
más fácil de resolver que la primera
pero una vez más cuando veo esto pues no
es un polinomio simple y no se puede
utilizar una sustitución porque una vez
más no hay como una función dentro de
una composición que tenga su derivada
por ahí en algún lugar entonces tal vez
sea una buena idea utilizar integración
por partes otra vez vamos a hacer eso
a ver vamos a suponer creo que ya más o
menos le vas agarrando la onda verdad
pero más o menos siguiendo como la misma
idea vamos a ponerle que es el jefe xy
éste de acá es que prima de que vamos a
hacer integración por partes dentro de
la integración por partes
entonces si hacemos así las cosas
entonces esta integral va a ser igual
este - sc - de acá
esta integral va a ser igual a fx por
gdx fx es simplemente 2 x x gx este eje
prima pero una vez más sigue prima sea
la x entonces g es la x entonces
simplemente ponemos aquí abajo un ala x
y ahora que hay que hacer tenemos que
restar la integral
tenemos que restar la integral de la
derivada de la primera función y la
derivada de 2x es 2 entonces ponemos
aquí 12 y luego hay que multiplicar por
la anti derivada de ea la equis pero
está fácil verdad otra vez nos queda a
la x
saleh
interesante creo que ya ves más o menos
lo que va a pasar verdad a ver déjame
poner aquí el x cuadrada a la equis que
nos faltaba para que no se nos olviden
que íbamos y mira ahora si esta integral
ya es se ve muy fácil para resolver aquí
me falta un de x entonces cuál es la
integral de la vera y te voy a pasar
este 2 aquí afuera voy a poner el 2 aquí
y cuál es la integral de ea la x cuál es
la integral de ea el x pues es
simplemente a la x entonces ya vamos a
poder vamos a poder simplificar está
integrada ahora sí entonces vamos a
copiar las cosas aquí abajo nos queda
esto igual a equis cuadrada por ea la x
- hay que distribuir este menos verdad
menos 2x a la x ahora menos por menos da
más menos porque nos da más
entonces nos queda más dos veces verdad
menos por menos da más baja vamos bien
ok entonces nos queda la anti derivada
de a la equis que simplemente es que a
like y por supuesto recuerda que no se
nos debe olvidar el más c
muy bonito fíjate encontramos que la
integral de x cuadrada a la x
v x es igual a esta expresión que está
muy bonita
supongo que al principio cuando
aprendimos a integrar nunca te
imaginaste que podríamos llegar a
resolver este tipo de ejercicios podrías
intentar resolver unos más difíciles
como x a la n por el aa la equis
resuelta que sale igual y hay que
utilizar integración por partes varias
veces pero cada vez que lo hacemos el
exponente del de la equis se hace más
pequeño hasta que llegamos a simplemente
una ea la equis intenta no intentarlo
por tu cuenta a ver qué pasa
podría ser un poquito tedioso pero al
menos ya hay una forma muy sistemática
para hacerlo resulta que integración por
partes es una de las técnicas más
flexibles que existen para integrar en
donde está todo el truco es poder
identificar quién es jefe y quién es que
prima haré un vídeo más para seguir
entendiendo esta técnica vamos a
resolver un problema clásico vas a ver
que está bien padre después de eso tal
vez sea una buena idea hacer un vídeo
con un montón de integrales mixtas para
que te cuente cómo le hago yo para saber
qué técnica a utilizar no te lo prometo
pronto pero espero poder hacerlo en un
par de semanas bueno nos seguimos viendo
y hasta pronto